In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for June 28 on which we commemorate the recovery of
the relics of the holy and wonder-working unmercineries, Cyrus and John.
On the 28th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the translation of the relics of
the holy unmercineries, Cyrus and John.
Under the glorious martyrdom of the holy unmercineries, Cyrus and John, devout Christians hid their
bodies in the Church of St. Mark for fear that the pagans would profane them.
Many years later, in about the year 412, during the reign of Theldosios the younger, our
Holy Father Cyril, who had just succeeded his uncle, Theophilos, on the throne of Alexandria,
was praying to God with tears to show him how to fight against what remained of idolatrous
cults, in particular that of Isis the healer at Manuthus near Canopus.
An angel appeared to him and ordered him to translate the relics of the two holy martyrs,
Cyrus and John, to a church dedicated to the holy evangelists, which Theophilos had built
not far from the pagan sanctuary.
The holy bishop called together his clergy and the people, and after having told them about
his vision, took his stand at the head of a sumptuous procession, which was joined by almost
the whole population of Alexandria.
Arriving at the Church of St. Mark, they opened the tombs of the holy martyrs that had fallen
into oblivion, and found that their relics were incorrupt and resplendent with the grace
of the Holy Spirit.
They placed the relics on a cart and proceeded to Manuthus, amidst a great crowd of people
singing hymns and songs, accompanied with lights and the smoke of fragrant incense.
Immediately miracles began to be wrought.
The sick were healed, the possessed delivered, the blind recovered their sight, the lame
walked, just as during the time of the Lord's public life.
When the relics were placed in the church of the holy evangelists, the demon who lived
in the temple of Isis fled in terror, and the pagan priests, seeing all the miracles, came
to throw themselves at the archbishop's feet and asked to be baptized.
In time, the abandoned temple disappeared into the sands, while the sanctuary of the holy
martyrs drew ever-increasing crowds from all parts of the empire, who came seeking the
aid of the saints.
Numerous hostilities were built around the sanctuary to receive the pilgrims, but the sick would
spend the night near the saints' tombs, kissing them with devotion and anointing themselves
with the oil from the sanctuary lamps, or drinking the water from the fountain which stood
outside the church.
Inumerable miracles were wrought through the intercession of these holy unmercineries,
who would often reveal to the sick the means through which they might be healed, appearing
to them in dreams, or even when awake.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.